do you get the caller or do you make the
call I get the call
I was like oh my god this is my worst
thing moment
[Music]
hello and welcome to women balls where I
Katie balls speak to today's
Trailblazers my guest today was born in
Glasgow where she started her career in
journalism as a football reporter
a fellow colleague said she turned up
for work one day and just kept coming
back this driven nature continued
throughout her career moving to work for
the conserved party as a press officer
then later selected by Theresa May to be
her closest Ally in the home office in
2016 when may became prime minister she
moved to number 10 as the first female
Chief of Staff in Downing Street
she covered all areas of maize political
career from the modern slavery act
brexit negotiations to the 2017 general
election she resigned after that general
election when the conservatives lost
their majority now she runs her own
strategic consultancy specializing in
policy reputation and crisis management
describing one former colleague that
she's a woman is neither here nor there
she's just a professional my guest today
is Fiona hill now to begin on this
podcast Fiona and thank you for joining
because she's been a very high on my
list of people I've been very keen to
get on for some time thank you Casey
um would you describe yours as a happy
childhood
overall yes
um I am exceptionally close to my
siblings
um my sister Amy is um 12 years younger
than me so she keeps me young
um and my brother is four years younger
and we're just really really tight and
also my mother is a force of Nature and
just be cool really
um so the mixture of that combination
was a happy part
um there was a few challenges with my
father and they got divorced and so that
was a less happy part but I'd never
really think about that too much because
I think every child who's a chat has a
challenge but overall pretty happy
and what were you like at school were
you well behaved were you a force of
nature like your mother what was the
vibe
um a set of contradictions Katie
um I wrecked hard
um sometimes
um and I was fairly straight laced
um but I also have quite a mischievous
character and every now and then I might
have exercised that
I'm so old now you see Katie I can't
remember
but the teachers loved you I was always
a teacher's pet that's good yeah
um and was politics discussed much in
your family growing up yes very much so
I mean that was the thing that we spoke
about at lunch dinner you know it was
something that I remember speaking about
very very early on in my life I remember
mum telling me that when I was five I
refused to watch John Craven's news
round because it was too boring and I
wanted to watch the news at nine as it
was then
um and then I told my mother that I
would become a journalist and then go
into politics
um so I think I pretty much set my own
strategy and stuck to it
um let's talk about that career
journalism because I mentioned the
introduction
um you were a football reporter very
well and perhaps Scotland's first female
reported I think I might have been there
is another girl who came on the scene
not long after me but I can't because I
don't like uh you know pretending
um I I do think I have a surprised
um but she definitely came on I can't
remember her name though but she worked
on one of the other Glasgow newspapers
and if you're a football reporter are
you allowed to have your favorite team
or are you supposed to be neutral
um I think you're probably supposed to
be neutral
um but fortunately for me I was always
on the big games like code and beef
versus uh Beric uh so it was easier to
be shall we say I'm neutral with the
smaller teams and um what was and I
wondered first how did you get into
football reporting and to what was the
what was it like at the time did you
have because I didn't a lot today about
sports reporting and how
females particularly in football aren't
taken so seriously do you have much of
that
I think that's fair to see
um I mean I I saw the funny side of it
because it was so Preposterous
um really I mean I I got into it because
um when I was leaving University I knew
I wanted to be a journalist
and actually in truth I think I probably
needn't have gone to University even
though I quite enjoyed it because I
really did know what I wanted to do
um and I took a job as a receptionist on
The Daily Record and Sunday Mail
because I thought I'd use that as a
launch pad into the editorial side
so I sent
um the editor Malcolm speed who was very
nice a copy of my CV with a tea bag
stapled to it saying enjoy over a Cuppa
um and he seemed to find this quite
amusing breakfasty
um actually it's probably techniques
yeah it wasn't very sophisticated then
Katie
um obviously I'm no yes
um but yeah so like he he liked that and
so he said okay let's give you some work
experience on the free sheet which was
called the glass region
and
um I did my work experience there and I
had a center page Splash after a couple
of days and realized actually I quite
enjoyed this and they realized I was
fairly good at it
um and then someone I I don't know who
came up with the idea that actually they
should make me do football
um and so I did football
um and you mentioned earlier on that
your early career plan from a young age
was obviously journalism and then moved
to politics so even when you're doing
football reporting was that was still
what you had crazy in mind yeah yeah
I mean I I came from the west coast of
Scotland and I didn't have a big contact
spoke
um and no one in my family had any
position in journalism and politics and
I worked out that the way of getting to
the place I wanted to be in politics was
going through journalism and making
contacts that way so at what point do
you then you had a brief stint doing PR
because my editor before we recorded
this Fraser Nelson
um so that you once tried to help
organize a stag do and very very helpful
and resourceful person you can turn my
hand to be anything
so what was the pr stage of your career
like did you like it I'd been working at
Sky News uh it's Deputy news editor and
I was acting up as news editor and I
started to look at you know well when do
I go into politics because obviously I'd
had that always in in my mind
um and I then also worked out that it
was highly unlikely that I would never
be made you know ahead of domestic news
because there are just so few of those
jobs in broadcasting
um and the competition is quite stiff
and they're very few women
um so I thought well okay maybe it's
time to to move and I went to the uh
Conservative Party Conference uh
the one with David Cameron and DeDe and
so forth were doing leadership
um campaign and I saw um David speaking
in a warm-up and I just saw actually
really like this guy I think this is the
time to go into politics I always knew I
was a conservative and so I ended up
in this PR job because I left Sky
because a friend who worked there uh
persuaded me to go there but it was the
worst three months of My Life
um I was terrible at it and
um I just hated it so much and then I
was fortunate enough to have an
introduction made with Henry McCrory and
Michael Salter who worked at cchk and
the rest is history
um why did you always know you're a
conservative
were your parents conservatives my
grandmother very much was and and my
mother uh for me I guess it was a
reaction to growing up in a very labor
place and I didn't really like their
attitude to many things actually
and also I really don't want the state
interfering in my life and I don't think
that the state should be the answer to
everything and I felt that when I was
younger
um and that it just kind of gradually
moved I guess uh from from there it was
it was an instinctive thing for me
really
so you joined the conservative party
press office and this is when the
victories are in opposition
um so what is the mood like does it feel
as though they're on the cusp of
something or is no one quite sure yet
well I joined in January 2007.
what year did David become leader it was
November whatever January it was after
he became you know that's when I joined
um and you know I just had a bowl
actually Katie wolves
um because I I just loved the people
that I worked with
um and you know we had so much fun
and I think that we worked really really
well as a team
it was probably a bit early at that
stage to think that we were on the cusp
of something but all I know is that the
atmosphere was right because we were all
fairly young
um fairly bright and knew what we wanted
to do and how to do it and you know
David and George were very very good at
leading in opposition and you know it
was just fun you know
um when do you meet Theresa May
um I think actually I first met Theresa
May when I was a journalist at Sky
um probably a Party Conference but the
first time I got to know how
um vaguely well was one of the other
press officers I had a couple of weeks
off and I stood in for her
um and then worked for her for a couple
of weeks and I think I got her a front
page Splash because I made a right to
Sir Alan sugar complaining about
something
um so I think that stuck in her mind
um so she went to the home office a
mixture of her and and obviously Nick
and I knew each other in opposition and
got on very very well and so that's how
the the team came together and did you
immediately see in her the type of
politician where you had quite similar
values
um I I didn't know her well enough to
make that judgment in opposition really
um that took a bit of time being in the
home office and getting to know her a
bit more personally
um
so we've we've skipped to the point
where the tourism are in power yeah and
you're in the home office of Theresa May
and I wonder what what was the
transition like from obviously uh
working in the tourism opposition he's
making all the positives to suddenly
you're in what many regards the
trickiest department there's a reason
it's often called you know the graveyard
of Ambitions because it's just so large
that there are lots of problems we've
seen home secretaries such as Amber Rudd
you know struggle with it
um so how how does your job change is it
quite daunting at that point I mean it's
it's a kind of vertical learning curve
that unless you've experienced it you
can't really understand it
I mean one of the reasons that I called
my consultancy Marshall Street
Consultants is because I just loved
being there I mean I absolutely loved
that job and I loved because I really do
like learning and I loved the pace at
which I had to learn how much I had to
read how much I had to get under the
skin of the department the the scale of
the the challenge I was quite like a
challenge and everything
um and yeah I mean I I just felt very
very motivated and really happy that I
was learning that much that quickly
because you really do go from uh a
knowledge of of uh very little really
apart from how journalism works or you
know how you think about policy to this
big operational department where there's
risk everywhere and there's nothing more
intellectually satisfying than working
in a risk environment for me I just
completely you know get off on it if
that's the right terminology probably
not the spectator listeners
um but yeah I mean it's what it's what
makes me jump out of bed in the morning
and and also actually I had become very
immersed in the modern slavery agenda
and we've just finished the the
legislation
but the legislation I knew only covered
off and and helped one angle of modern
slavery and had become very very
interested in the security side of it
the organized crime part of it so that's
when I went to the CSG and researched
and wrote a paper looking at organized
crime in relation to trafficking across
Europe yeah because I was going to say
one of the questions I have is one of
our contributors James Kirk once
suggested it it's probably fair to say
that Mrs may only talks about modern
slavery because of Ms Hill
um I don't think he would go that far
but well I mean there was a day that I
was speaking about it so much that she
asked me to stop
but but you know I'm I'm the kind of
person that if I see something that that
I I feel passionate about I I do become
borderline obsessed so I'm just on
Modern slavery I wonder because it's one
of the things I think to this day is
seen as the legacy of Theresa Mayhem
we'll talk more about the trees made
Premiership of course but what was it
that then made it something that you
were so focused in on was that
particular experience or
fight anyone
in my stone and here's the story of
someone who's been trafficked and then
exploited to not then become quite
obsessed with it and to understand
really what lies behind it I've met
women and men who have told me stories
that I couldn't even tell you on on your
podcast I'm afraid but once you hear
those stories you can't unhear them
um and just a sheer tragedy I mean
one woman who had been trafficked from
from Africa
um she went through the most horrendous
abuse and she was only 26 when I spoke
to her and she'd just been diagnosed
with breast cancer that day and I
couldn't believe how unlucky one person
could be and
that when you know that and you know
that you're working in a an environment
that you you can do something about it
even if it's a tiny thing you can't go
to bed at night and not
you just can't and the more I looked
into it the more I realized that this
wasn't just a social condition or a
social issue
um and it wasn't just a migration issue
really at its heart it was organized
Crichton and organized criminals are so
agile and so better at getting things
done in governments that I became very
passionate and and
you know just very serious about how we
could get government and its
institutions to be a bit clever
and understand really what was lying
behind it because organized crime is you
know illegal Firearms it's it's uh drug
crime and yet human trafficking wasn't
seen in that bundle but it makes huge
amounts of profits for organized
criminals huge would you say there was a
gap in the law on it or there's a huge
gap and there's still it still is
um and we set up the modern slavery task
force to try and uh fill that Gap and we
had the head of MI6 head of MI5 the head
of mod intelligence because to to come
down hard on something like organized
crime in the same way that you do for
counterterrorism you really need
multi-disciplinary teams to be able to
do it and I knew that they weren't doing
it and I wanted them to do it so I
thought well let's eyeball them and see
if we can get them to do it
um
now
you have your period outside of
government and then in 2016 we're going
to skip past the referendum because
otherwise we're never going to leave
this room
but ultimately we all know what happens
leave wins David Cameron no longer feels
able to stay in this place he steps down
lots of people think this is going to be
a Boris Johnson coronation instead
Theresa May enters the race and and the
rest is history
um at what point do you start to work
for Theresa May in terms of her bid to
be leader about two hours after David
resigned
and do you get the caller or do you make
the call I get the call
we've watched the West Winger so many
problems of course so you know the
episode where
um Sam is in this very boring corporate
meeting talking about about shipbuilding
M A or something similar
um and Josh basically knocks on the
glass window and says it's time
I've always wanted to be in that
position and then I was like oh my god
this is my wrestling moment
um and at the time did you did were you
confident she had a good chance of
winning because I think Lots I was
convinced she was gonna yeah we were
very prepared I mean we pretty much had
everything in place before if I'm honest
David resigned
um so we knew exactly what we were doing
and one of the reasons I thought she
would win despite uh it looking like it
was because Boris dropped out
um I knew that she could bridge the gap
between both sides of the party the
remaining the brexit and at that time
that was very very critical
um and people really knew that she was
reliable she'd done five years
fairly untarnished at the home office
and ultimately that shows our
credibility that that no one else could
show
so although everyone just assumed that
Boris would get it and and I didn't work
on that assumption
um so Theresa May has crowned crowns
wrong word but Theresa becomes prime
minister and you've become the first
ever female Chief of Staff yeah
we'll get Nick Timothy can have a bit of
space but he's spoken enough so so
you've become the first female co-chief
of Staff alongside Nick Timothy who's
your home of his colleague
um wasn't like your first day in number
10. I just talk us through it I remember
I was walking towards number 10 and a
number of my friends who worked for
David Cameron were walking towards the
cabinet office because they were leaving
and I remember thinking I don't like
this feeling I don't like watching my
friends leave
um I knew why they were leaving because
they were all exhausted after the main
campaign
um but I do remember feeling that this
was not likely to be a happy time
and indeed it was not
that's really interesting was that was
that without a specific reason or just a
feeling because obviously you had the
tricky task so that's an understatement
of brexit
um was it that was it just it's just a
sense
I mean the the sense of shock that
reverberated around that building for a
very long time was palpable
and it never quite left in the time that
I was there people just couldn't believe
what had happened and that was before we
got into the negotiations and and how we
actually even start the the negotiation
and again I think that in certain
meetings there was just a general sense
that continued of of you know disbelief
that we were even having these
conversations so that brexit happened
yeah that David Cameron had got it was a
combinational
I mean it was just that brexit happened
and it did feel like the surface of the
Sun in there you know it something big
had happened and it
for me anyway I
I didn't find
although I'd always wanted to have that
job I didn't find her at least I had to
work harder to try and
scope it in a way that I would at least
get something out of it
because that's one of the things about
moving to dining Street whereas you have
some people who in departments do very
well but then they moved to Downing
Street and I Municipal cost lots of
different roles but it's just such a
different way of working fairly
different way of working
um but that's okay yeah
um you know it's not as operational as a
department like the home offices but I
was okay with that because I was fairly
interested in the NSC and that agenda
and that's pretty operational
um and then actually just trying to keep
I don't know a sense of calm
um in the country by announcing things
or doing things that that lead to
people's fears of well what's next
um and that's what we were trying to do
I think we were fairly successful at
doing that in you know before the
election of 2017 that will forever be
etched all of my body I was going to say
initially the polls were recording you
know huge support there was what some
described as May Mania
um in terms of and I think you go to
that local election result which was not
that long before the general election
and the Tories were you know actually
you know a very positive place so if I
was there in the initial
days and weeks it was going to plan did
it feel like that on the inside yeah
yeah I felt like it was going to plan
until we got into the 2017 election
so on that Theresa May call the election
it's
after they've been strong suggestions
she would not do that
um
what did you did you support the
decision to call an early election yeah
yeah I know and I still think it's the
right I think it was the only thing that
we had to do because the majority was so
slim and if you look now back with
hindsight how difficult it has been
since then there is no way that we
couldn't try out and have an election
and and based on as you said Katie the
polls indicated that we would win fairly
well
um what of course you can't make into
your thinking is whether or not the
campaign you ultimately run has the
right momentum and I don't think the
2017 election campaign ever really had
the right momentum for a number of
reasons some in our gift and a lot
outside our control
but with election campaigns they're
almost like the voodoo that you knew so
well
um
you can get luck
and you can also get bad luck and it
doesn't matter if you've got your
messages right or this and that right or
wrong
um sometimes it's just a quite
unquantifiable uh momentum or or indeed
otherwise there's always a bit of luck
on politics too yeah and life in general
what do you think went wrong that was in
the control I suppose of theres May
those around her
um
well I I mean
I think I don't think I didn't get a
sense that she was really enjoying it
yeah
um
and I think that ultimately journalists
pick up on that in a campaign
um I think and I think it's documented
that I wasn't a supporter of the social
health care policy
um it was a very long campaign I mean it
took me weeks to catch up on sleep I
mean it really was a tough campaign what
was it about the social care policy
specifically that you just well I I
direct with Jeremy Hayward on it in
government we're actually number 10.
um and I knew that it had been tested
properly
um it's only been tested inside the
confines of the Civil Service my view
was to really get under the uh the skin
of of what what it was is that it should
go out to see like the king's fund or
some go out somewhere and be tried and
tested and then come back into
government
I of course understand that we need to
do something about social health care
but I didn't feel like this policy which
was a complex policy complex if
something's complex to understand or to
communicate then it means that it hasn't
been tried and tested enough and I
didn't feel it had been yeah let me see
that a lot
the recent governments
um I suppose I want to just
on Election night
was there a point you thought perhaps
the Tories would lose that election
was there a point before or if not I
wanted
there was a Mormon after the Manchester
um Arena bombing where we were uh
traveling by plane up to uh Manchester
and the window uh cockpit Windows
shattered
and we had to drop
uh a couple of I'm terrible with metrics
I'm afraid but we had to um
um and and I hadn't really been feeling
particularly great about the general
direction of the campaign anyway but
there was something about that moment
that that I I felt was a bit of an omen
and that I felt
like I said you know some bad things
happen during campaigns and um
and it's hard
you know to campaign for politics when
people have lost their life I mean you
know that's a really ugly thing had
happened you're not going out and seeing
strong and stable too much after that
yeah
um and so that slows everything down and
it has to absolutely has to
um but overall I I just felt things were
not going to plan
and when the exit poll came through
because I remember coming through just
doing a live blog from next door and it
was a site like spit your tea out of
your mug moment what was your reaction
well um one of the best things I did
that uh D stroke evening was
um I got my sister to come into cchq
um and I I think it must have been
around
maybe 10 to 5 to 10 but as you can
imagine my memory is a bit blurry and
Andy Mark called me and told me
but the exit poll Wards and I felt like
basically I'd been kicked in the stomach
and I was aware that I was there in in
body but I wasn't really there at all in
my mind
um
and I was just so grateful for my sister
being there because you know she kind of
directed me almost
um and then of course I had to tell Nick
and then I had a call from Theresa
asking me to go down to the constituency
which I did but I don't think I was
there very long she had her account and
then I was in another car coming back up
to cchq
and my sister had stayed on in the hotel
room I was staying and thank goodness
um and then I got there about five
o'clock in the morning and she'd already
packed up all my clothes and poured me
into a taxi and the sister yeah she's a
wonderful sister
um and I felt bad for my sister and
particularly for my brother during that
period because my brother was a BBC
journalist in Westminster and I can't
imagine how it would have felt for him
going into work the next day felt quite
guilty about that so all in all it was
what we probably would describe as a low
point in one's career do we think the
three months in the pr firm are still
worth do you know what probably
my sister wasn't there
um in the days that followed of course
you know
it was losing their mind there's
obviously a lot of uncertainty the deal
is being forged with the dep if you get
money and lots of MP stock quality you
know saying we can't go to reason makes
we're going to call the head of her two
powerful AIDS
so did you feel like you had no choice
but to resign
um yeah I mean I was supposed to resign
did you did you I didn't I didn't
personally think that I should be
resigning um because I didn't really
feel like
I'd necessarily done anything massively
wrong
um maybe with hindsight I don't know
maybe I did uh someone else can be the
judge of that it's difficult for me to
do it for myself
um but just you know straightforwardly
you know she called me and said you have
to resent
so I resigned it must be tricky in
politics when you've obviously dedicated
so much it's obviously your career too
in the sense as we said you're the first
ever female co-chief of Staff as well as
football reporter but you know it's a
very impressive crew in its own right
but obviously you're dedicating years of
your life to politicians career it must
be strange in a moment obviously
the politician keeps going but you're
almost potentially collateral yeah is
that something you felt at all or is it
not right I felt that acutely yeah I
mean of course uh she had to keep going
and I understand the rules of politics
and life and I understood that I had to
be collateral damage and she did the
right thing sacking I was I mean Nick
was already resigning anyway
um
and
you know as much as I understood all the
reasons
for the weeks and months that followed I
felt like there was a lack of protection
around me and what was written about me
and
a lot of what was written about me
wasn't entirely accurate and I found
that quite hard even though I was a
former journalist I know how it works um
and I know how politics works and now
you know of course I accept it it's not
not a thing anymore but at the time
it was
just really horrible actually no I was
going to ask you that because it just
felt a bit like it became like a Feeding
Frenzy it felt it felt like that yeah
and I didn't bother complaining about it
because I knew well firstly I didn't
know who to complain to
um and secondly I knew that it was a
frenzy so it was unlikely that anything
I said would stop the frenzy
the one thing I would see though is
and I still believe this that for a
fairly young woman not that young
um who lives by herself
um to be allowed to be thrown to the
roofs like that was potentially
not very goods luckily I'm a strong
person but if I'd been a lesser person I
may have thrown myself an attempt
um and then after about three or four
weeks
you know someone tried to break into my
flat and it turned out that it was
probably a political thing he laughed
when I screamed he laughed
um so these were all the byproducts of
having your uh profile raised in that
kind of way and I think too often in
politics people forget that actually we
are all human beings and that sometimes
you can take the collateral because you
know that that's the game but I don't
think that there's any harm in having
some form of safety net for those people
who are taking that collateral did you
have any support kind of after reach out
you know protection my mother my brother
my sister
um because it felt as there was a pretty
red Nick Timothy was in lots of places
obviously writing columns and you almost
kind of went to ground
I felt that I wanted to understand what
had just happened
and I didn't feel that I I had all the
uh the facts to hand because it all
happened in such a high octane way that
I just needed time to
um
really analyze everything that had taken
place and my own place in it
um and also
I just I I didn't really feel that I had
anything of any consequence to say at
that point
and also I'm very discreet and loyal and
if I hadn't said anything at that point
I'd have only fed the frenzy and that
would have been helpful to anyone
I mean Nick was different because he was
given the column in the Daily Telegraph
um so that allowed him to make
the next step into journalism and he'd
always wanted to eventually do that
but I didn't want to do that and I made
the calculation that I needed to let the
frenzy pass
and then rebuild my life and I wasn't
likely to be able to do that during a
frenzy
now I want to talk about the things
you're doing now the final thing I just
wanted on that was in that time and
reflecting is there anything you know
when you've had that time away and I
think were you in America for I went to
stay with my poor spend Laura in New
York who
I mean basically three months of saying
Laura how do I turn a computer on or
Laura um could you just fix this it
problem because you know until then I'm
not really I mean we had ps's and things
in government and then you're back to
doing it for yourself
um and she was a good friend for uh
putting up with me and my it limitations
um did you is there anything with
hindsight having had that time for about
you would have done differently
from the time
if they in truth it's a very difficult
period for me uh Katie because uh
my partner had been diagnosed with
cancer
and so for me a lot of it is a bit of a
blur yeah because I was keeping it all
together
and
would I do anything differently probably
but I couldn't point to one thing yeah
but evidently I'm not in that job
anymore so something went wrong
and what you know and I take my
responsibility for for
you know whatever went wrong as much as
I'm sure Nick and Theresa wrote
I mean no one seems to stay in that job
very long these days don't you know
um
so now outside of government
um you've spoken a bit about the
Consultants you're doing now you're also
for a time back at the csj yeah
um so in terms of your day-to-day now
what is your focus
you know what you spoke a bit about um
having the home office students like
getting up and high stakes and as what
gets you going is that what you have now
too I do I've got myself and and it has
taken a taken a long time I mean you
know 2017 was five years ago
um I'm glad I took my time actually
I think it's good to go slow when you're
rebuilding because you want to get the
next phase of your life absolutely right
and I feel like I've got there and
a bit like I was saying in relation to
general election campaigns having that
momentum and things just start working
and you can start seeing the light at
the end of the tunnel and you know that
um and everyone has this you have your
moments when you in life where you go
through your downturn and you just have
to get through it but then you start
realizing that you're going through the
next phase again which is the good the
good times before you ultimately get to
the bad times again let's face it but
but
um but you know I've got I've got a
sense that when I get out of bed in the
morning I'm doing interesting things I'm
speaking to interesting people
um the clients I have are
um diverse and just really really
interesting interesting regions and so
forth
um
I know I'm about to well not about to
I'm already starting to organize an
International Security conference which
we'll have here in the UK
um nothing to do with UK government I'm
organizing this by myself
and that would be next October on the
9th and the 10th um I can't see yet
where it will be but it's a pretty
groovy venue
and that will keep me occupied for a
while
um so I yeah I mean I I've uh I've I've
made a life for myself which I'm very
very comfortable in
and you once around for a seat I think
unless I was on the list but I didn't
ever go for any seats you're not tempted
now good goodness
no
medical saying I would presume it was a
no but just just wanted I I do not
cherish the job of
MP
um I just have two final questions the
first was just one which is
but currently obviously even more Tory
turbulence
how much of a problem do you think are
political grudges and politics I don't I
don't think it's just
or rather I don't think uh division
applies just to the Tory party or indeed
Westminster I think the division is the
byproduct of a very changing world and a
world that's changing in a way that is
uh is is quite concerning
and because things are starting to get
quite serious
we all know that the risks involved and
the threats and that we're facing are
are fairly big and probably of the kind
that we've never thought we would see in
our generation and ultimately I think
that is making people uh quite anxious
and in terms of what we do about it or
what those people who work in politics
do about it I think that they have to
see the bigger picture
we can't have a population living in
fear
they need to feel like the people who
are paid to lead have to lead and those
who leads have to understand that
that threat isn't just a foreign policy
or a security threat anymore it's a
threat that people actually feel in
their own homes
um and I'm not talking about mortgages
know that I'm talking just people waking
up in the morning listening to the news
watching the news they know things are
changing they worry about their children
their grandchildren what kind of world
they will live in and we are those in
power need to Steward the country
through that
now the final question is when I ask
everyone on this podcast which is um
what is the worst advice you've ever
been given and you could have taken up
you could have just completely ignored
it I have a feeling you may have ignored
it I I your that feeling would be right
but actually there's two uh pieces of
advice that I didn't think in the end
happen to be very good one I did take
and regretted it and then the other one
I didn't take oh fabulous have both okay
so the one that I didn't take
um in Scotland and I don't know if you
had this when you're at school in
Scotland and we had a thing called
Career advisors my mother is a career
advisor oh no no you might be about no
don't worry she's retired no she was a
brief career but in Scottish school so
this is this is particularly good okay
well my career advice advisor was
um a man who was quite returned and uh
shiny
uh shall we say and I wrote to him and I
said I want to be a journalist and he
said I wouldn't do that he said you
don't know anyone in journalism it's a
very nepotistic industry you'll never
get a job and I was absolutely
incandescent so I sat down and wrote a
letter to the Headmaster and I said I
just don't think that it's very good for
career advisors to tell people they
can't do something we should be telling
people they can do something and then
became a journalist so
see ya
um and then the less fortunate piece of
advice which I actually did
did take up boys
um on the Friday morning I found out
that I got my job at the Scotsman and I
was obviously super excited about this
because I'd always wanted to work on the
Scotsman and especially that old
building which is now a hotel it was a
real romantic dream I had
and so rather excitedly I hit a Glasgow
nightclub with a few friends and we
ordered some sambuca and my friend said
to me you need to light your sambuca
which I did but then burnt my lips so
started uh the first day the job that
I'd been painting for for many years
with shall we see a slightly swollen lip
some people would pay for that these
days
um do you know actually maybe I'll do
that yeah
I've got an injection with that thank
you for joining us Stephanie pleasure
thank you very much
[Music]